hi everyone matt here thanks for tuning
in before we get started with this great
episode i'd like to invite you to join
us on linkedin
find the think fast talk smart page and
follow us for conversation updated
information new ideas and a great
opportunity for us to interact
the very first class i ever took in
college was an economics class
i learned so much and i learned how
little i knew about economics
today i look forward to continuing that
education
i'm matt abrahams and i teach strategic
communication at stanford graduate
school of business
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast
today i'm excited to be joined by paul
oyer
he is the mary and rankin and
entrepreneurial professor
and professor of economics additionally
paul is senior associate dean for
academic affairs at the gsb he studies
the economics of organizations and human
resource practices
paul also has a unique research approach
he drove for uber studied online dating
and he explores the sports world in his
newest book an economist goes to the
game how to throw away 580 million
dollars and other surprising insights
from the economics of sports
hey paul welcome to the podcast i am
super excited to have you here i am
super excited to be here thanks matt
awesome let's get started first
congratulations on your new book in this
book like your previous book roadside
mba you teach us important often
unexpected economic lessons
i'm curious what motivates your research
and approach and do you have any
favorite
notions or ideas that stick out from
your writing and research yeah i just
think the main thing that really try
that i try to get across is that
economics is everywhere it's an
incredibly powerful lens to analyze
almost anything in the real world and i
think a lot of listeners might think oh
economics that's very abstract and dry
remembering some class they took in
economics i mean in college but i i see
it very differently everywhere you look
economics is guiding what's going on so
you mentioned the book roadside mba
which i wrote with a couple of other
economists and in that book it was a
strategy book for small business people
there were no numbers and equations none
of that it was just taking simple
economic ideas and seeing how small
business owners could put them into
action so for example in that book we
talked to a bowling alley owner in
kansas and this guy was very interesting
and he had the problem of too many
people applying for every job and so he
would put a job listing in the paper and
so many people would come down
and he wanted to separate the sort of
serious people from the not so serious
people and he said i remember him
telling us he definitely ruled out the
people who showed up in their pajamas
which i was surprised was an issue
but the other lesson he told us was he
said look i learned at some point put in
the ad bring a pencil so you can fill in
the application
and it was that little test of whether
you cared enough to notice that and
bring it that sounds so simple but it
really is a classic economic model from
mike spence the former dean of the gsb
that kind of
can explain that behavior i'm not saying
that the bowling alley guy had read mike
spence's paper i'm afraid that probably
was not true but mike spence was able to
capture
through an economic model an idea that
was very powerful in the real world the
same goes i i wrote a book where i talk
about economics and how you can
understand online dating again the first
chapter of that book is taking this
nobel prize winning idea i didn't win
the nobel prize a couple of people
including a labor economist named dale
mortensen did for what's known as search
theory and if you take their ideas
that model explains what we think of as
settling in the dating market so people
are very afraid of settling in the
dating market and it's really believe it
or not that's an economic concept and
then the final example i give you is out
of the new book
my favorite there's so many great sports
things about economics but my one of my
favorites in the new book is
korean women golfers
completely dominate the sport that goes
down to some basic underlying
things such as the savings rate in korea
the way schools are set up and then the
gender pay gap in the korean labor
market so again all the context that
runs through all of those is economics
is a powerful lens by which to
understand the world we live in
so by understanding economics we can
have a better understanding of the world
and and the take home message here don't
wear pajamas to interviews
and make sure that you have a pencil
when you show up very good
uh as you know this podcast focuses on
communication can you share a lesson or
two from your research that provides
some insight into communication sure i
study what's known as personnel or
organizational economics which is the
economics within firms
and it's not just in that setting but in
many settings economists
focus on the importance of credibility
so it's not the way you or i would think
about like how do you speak how does
obama or somebody is really good come
across as credible it's how do my
actions separate
things that i say that may or may not be
true from things that are actual and
true and i think understanding the
economic concept of repeated games and
and how to make yourself credible is
really important for communication
absolutely we spend a lot of time
talking about credibility and how to
drive for congruence between what you
say and what you do and how others judge
you based on that credibility really is
important and i i didn't realize that i
was also teaching economics while i was
teaching communication everybody's
teaching economics i want to get back to
the serious stuff paul i want to go back
to your research on online dating can
you walk us through what cheap talk is
how it plays out in dating and in
business and how can we overcome it so
we're perceived as meaning what we say
often you can think about people when
they say something whether or not
there's any reason to believe them what
have they cheap talk is something you
can say where if it's true or not true
there's no obvious way to tell them
apart
so for example when i wrote this book
about online dating
the classic examples in there would be
online dating profiles men tend to
overstate their income and their height
for example so in a world of cheap talk
you can lie and get away with it but you
can't lie too big because when you
actually go to meet the person at some
point if you say you're six two if
you're six one or six or five eleven
maybe which then you have an incentive
to say you're six feet but if you were
really five four that's not going to be
a very good strategy so again it comes
back to where can you build credibility
an example of this in the sports book is
steroids any time you hear somebody say
i am not using performance-enhancing
drugs
you really have no reason to believe
them because the person who is and is
not using them
have the incentive to say exactly the
same thing
so a good mechanism for getting rid of
cheap talk is one where you can somehow
find a way to separate
the cheaters from the non-cheaters or
the liars from the non-liars however you
want to look at it so beyond studying
online dating and cheap talk you also
chose to drive an uber
what was that experience like and what
did you learn from it except how to get
places better you know you don't learn
how to get places better because these
days of ways can
ways can take you anywhere you want to
go so that's not that useful for that
for from that perspective so i'm a labor
economist and in addition to writing
these books i write research papers i've
studied lawyers i've studied the market
for investment bankers and a bunch of
other trades and boy i wish i could
try those jobs for two weeks because you
learn so much that helps structure your
research questions well we started
studying uber and this was joint
research with my stanford colleague
rebecca diamond and a few other people
we started studying uber and you can do
that the barriers to entry to being an
uber driver are so low that i just went
and registered my car and tried it and
it was fascinating now the main benefits
of it were from the research study
perspective where i learned a lot about
how to think about the value of
experience in that context which was
really important for what we were doing
but it also just was fun i don't want to
be an uber driver for my whole life i'm
very lucky that i'm able to work at
stanford but
i really wish i could do it both for the
research side but also it was just
interesting
so at the same time as i was doing that
job my stepson was working at chipotle
and we were making about the same amount
of money
and it was interesting because there's a
large set of people for whom working at
a job like working at chipotle is a much
better fit because they like the
camaraderie
and they like being told to be here this
hour and leave at this hour there's a
larger set who need the flexibility who
like the alone time
and so
it's nice that there are these various
options out there and then there's just
other really interesting stuff that at
least in the short term makes driving
for uber interesting for example i was
very lucky i didn't do it for that long
i never had a passenger who was nasty
they were always pleasant interesting
people some of them were very quiet but
some of them were interesting
and then also you drive all around the
bay area and you see these neighborhoods
that you only pass on the highway and
it's like wow what is that neighborhood
like that i've only seen on a 280 exit
ramp right
so i have i have a very personal
question for you what was your uber
rating when you were done ah that's a
great i it's 4.97 and i'm very i brag
about it a lot i could tell you and by
the way
there was one other economist who also
drove for uber his name is josh angrist
and he won the nobel prize but i had a
higher uber rating so i call it a draw
that's a that's a draw for sure as a
communication person i'm just i want to
drive
drive down this road a little farther
were there certain things you did that
you think increased your ratings as an
economist i would think you would have
some insight into things you could do to
improve your ratings well so for one
thing what i and this comes back to some
of the stuff i do research on for one
thing i never tried to game the ratings
and i think that in this case you don't
want to do that so i never told people
give me a high rating or
bribe them with mints or anything like
that i just tried to be courteous and on
time and do a good job and
now i did have a nice car so
i see maybe that helped so uh it sounds
to me like what helped you get such a
high rating a a above a nobel laureate's
rating was the fact that you were being
congruent incredible some of the stuff
we talked about earlier so
now you mentioned you're a labor
economist and so you've been studying
how work has been changing
i'm curious uh what have you concluded
and what advice would you have for those
listening in who are looking for work or
looking to change their work
so first of all i would say now is a
really good time to be looking for work
so a lot of what makes you successful in
the job market is
the macroeconomic conditions at the time
you're looking i've actually done
research on this showing the people who
graduate
uh during good economic times they have
they get benefits that last a long time
and by the same token now is a good time
to be switching jobs and finding just
the right job given the state of the job
market
but actually as a in terms of the
overall trends in the labor market
there's some evidence emerging and it's
a relatively new research area
to suggest the communication skills are
becoming more valuable in the labor
market we'll see how important it is and
how well that gets backed up but
because jobs are more
white collar in nature and often at a
distance and
and whatnot social and and communication
skills are becoming more important i
know writing a book takes a long time
from when you complete it to when it
comes out so i'm curious since you
finished your previous book what are you
currently working on what's the next
crazy job you're going to look into yeah
i wish i had a good a better answer to
that but mostly the crazy job i've been
looking into lately is being senior
associate dean of the stanford business
school
and i'm trying
trying to help
among many people here at the gsb keep
keeping the trains on the track during
covid which you know obviously was a
challenge to all educational
institutions everywhere so that was the
short-term thing but then in the longer
term
i think
we can now start turning our attention
to what did we learn from coved and as
the as the some of those technical
changes we talked about in the job
market
are taking hold in education what do we
need to do to keep uh the business
school up to date how should programs
change how should we the way we teach
change
and uh that's just an exciting thing to
be able to be part of here at the gsb
yeah and and i have to say as somebody
who is the recipient of your work and
and others i was very impressed with how
timely and transparent you were
things were changing dramatically and
it's not to say that mistakes weren't
made and things had to be adjusted but
but the transparency and timeliness was
very helpful and i think that's
important for all communications thanks
before we end i'd like to ask you the
same three questions i ask everyone who
joins me does that sound all right i
would love it if you were to capture the
best communication advice you have ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would that
be my answer's so unbelievably trite and
cliche but it's true and let's just keep
it simple
as academics and especially as
economists
we have such an urge such a natural urge
to complicate things
and
it's just
so unhelpful i mean
i would much rather get a simple message
across quickly and say it over and over
again than try to get through every
nuance
well said taking your advice excellent
very good my second question is who is a
communicator that you admire and why
can i cheat and give two answers
yes sir you may so there's a novel
there's the novelist richard russo he my
favorite book of his is empire falls but
he has many other great books
and then a
non-fiction writer who i read a lot of
his books he's now deceased william
manchester who wrote a biography of
churchill and a book some other many
other books i've read
what's great is
they communicate through stories
and they have a point
but
if they just said the point you wouldn't
remember it it's the way they weave it
together in a story that captures you
i'm very much an admirer of people who
do that
we have had jennifer on and we have
talked about story a lot and it's a
really important point you know just
giving data and lists are hard for us to
remember but if you can weave those
together into a clear narrative it can
be very helpful
final question
what are the first three ingredients
that go into a successful communication
recipe i think
both in economics and in my role in the
classroom a couple of things come to
mind one is
often i like to start presentations with
one graph that tells the whole story and
then the rest is just details one graph
and just the rest is is gravy i really
like that and along a similar line a
second idea is one story or anecdote
that exemplifies the point you want to
make so for example if i went in to
teach my expenses model i was talking
about earlier i'm i might start with a
graph
of some sort that gets at the idea
in the underlying economics and tell the
story of the pencil or something along
those lines
and then i think just in a setting like
an economic seminar in the classroom in
both those settings i think a third
ingredient would be
transparently and sincerely addressing
the questions and concerns that arise
the goal of learning
is it all comes from back and forth and
frankly from disagreements and arguments
so one thing i'd love to see us do more
at the gsb over time is
we're such a friendly place we are
afraid to disagree with one another and
i don't mean like disagree and fight and
be uncivil i mean civil disagreement
that leads to learning so
well i disagree no i actually agree with
everything that you've said there and
you're you're quite consistent i mean
really what you're talking about in
those first two ingredients is that
notion of credibility and being
congruent and then the the second uh
element there really is in line with
what you talked about earlier around
really engaging with the ideas well paul
it has been a pleasure to chat with you
your insights and approach to research
uh and the things you study are
fascinating i love that you you
experience the things that you you
research and best of luck with your new
book an economist goes to the game how
to throw away
580 million dollars in other surprising
insights from the economics of sports
thanks paul thank you so much matt
[Music]
you've been listening to think fast talk
smart the podcast a production of
stanford graduate school of business
this episode was produced by michael
reilly jenny luna and me matt abrahams
find more resources and join in the
conversation by searching linkedin for
think fast talk smart please download
and subscribe wherever you get your
podcasts
you